[Music]
this dodecahedral cage is made of silica
and it's tiny really tiny it was created
by researchers in the States who hoped
that one day it could help in the fight
against cancer
[Music]
to give you a sense of just how small
this nano cage is let's start with a
single grain of salt it's around 300
microns wide compare that to say a red
blood cell that's it there now compare
the red blood cell to something much
smaller like this the HIV virus the
silicon nano cage is a bit more than ten
times smaller than that to make it
researchers use a relatively simple
technique first they need a template for
that they use soap molecules when in
solution the soap molecules form tiny
balls called micelles the size of the
micelles is precisely controlled by the
researchers then they add a silica
precursor to the mix gradually the
negatively charged silica precursors are
attracted to the positively charged
micelle template over time they build up
forming the structure the template could
then be washed or burned out which would
leave a perfect dodecahedral cage what's
more this process happens without any
intervention it's self assembling this
is how the researchers think that the
cages form but until recently they
didn't even know they existed they're so
small it's nearly impossible to snap a
picture of them
to get that glimpse of the nanocages
researchers used cryo-electron
microscopy they put their sample on a
tiny disc and plunge it into liquid
nitrogen flash freezing it then they can
use an electron microscope to take a
peak making images that look a bit like
this they repeated the process over and
over to gather nearly 20,000 images of
the fuzzy looking cages all lying in
slightly different positions at
different angles and orientations now
here's the clever bit a computer can
analyze and average out all the
different images of all the different
orientations of the structure so feed
them into a computer and an algorithm
can reconstruct a 3d representation and
what popped out was a perfect
dodecahedron only 11 nanometers across
studies have shown that ultra-small
silica particles can easily and safely
pass through the body being excreted in
the urine rather than getting stuck in
the liver which can cause side effects
perhaps nanocages like these could be
used as containers for things like
anti-cancer drugs or as ultra small
vehicles to carry diagnostic molecules
but that is still a long way off
you